today
we shall see victory
a great new altered fights at our side
they asked you to help them why didn't
you my war is with the worst of our kind
they will destroy us all
i've heard such terrible terrible things
about you
how many of my people did you kill
just to reach
[Music]
well hello there people my name is lucy
and welcome back to another outriders
broadcast
today i am very excited because we get
to finally reveal to you outriders
worldslayer now we first teased the
existence of worldslayer back in
november last year where we also
introduced the free new horizon updates
which saw us add a whole plethora of
quality of life improvements and content
to the game and ever since then we have
been hard at work on outriders
worldslayer
but what exactly is it
let's get to it people today i present
to you
as outriders slayer the reveal trailer
there's the reckoning
coming
[Applause]
two paths diverge before you outrider
one leads to a new beginning
and the other
to pain
if we don't find a way to stop what's
coming
there will be nowhere for us to hide
you've been fighting for so long
that you've lost sight of what is true
there is no saving humanity
humanity is already dead
god
[Music]
we just had a glimpse into the story of
outriders world slayer introducing new
threats like a rescue gal the dark
altered overlord of the insurgents
you want to know more don't you
well we won't leave you hanging there in
fact i think i have just the right
person for the job
here is our resident expert on all
things worldslayer sven take it away
so you want to know what awaits you in
outrider's world slayer
think you're ready well let me tell you
you are not here we go
okay you've beaten out riders called
down the drop pods and crushed every
expedition to become supercharged
demigods
roaming the battlefields of enoch
but that doesn't mean your outriders can
kick back and relax just yet
no
i didn't believe it
but the anomaly
it's growing
outrider's world slayer we see the
anomaly has continued to evolve rising
to the challenge that you the outriders
have presented frost storms and
blizzards now ravage the land at a speed
that even enoch's hyper-evolved
monstrosities struggled to adapt to
and as if this wasn't bad enough
ereshkigal the commander of the human
insurgent faction has her own designs in
mind for the future of humanity on enoch
it gets better every day
against impossible odds the outrider
will have to push themselves to their
limits to help enoch see another day
if you want humanity to survive this
frozen onslaught
you will need to travel to some of the
furthest reaches of enoch
new lands of course also bring new
horrors and outriders wall slayer
doesn't just introduce new enemy
variants it adds entirely new
adversaries these all formulate a pretty
scary gang of beasts and bosses who are
very eager to say hello
unsure if your current gear will be good
enough for these adventures
yeah well it isn't but not to worry
outriders wall slayer adds a bunch of
new loot for you to hunt down including
badass weaponry as well as class
specific and universal legendary armor
sets more on that topic a bit later for
now let's have a look at our biggest new
features
the packs drew strength from the anomaly
in their own way
by exploring their past you too will be
able to unlock a secondary skill tree
which adds two more subclass branches
for each of the original classes points
for these new pax class trees unlock
after completing significant events in
outrider's world slayer
but even a new skill tree won't be
enough to reach the highest echelons of
difficulty
as an altered you will still need to
ascend ascension is the new long-term
progression system introduced in
outriders worldslayer
step by step it will allow you to
improve your endurance your brutality
your prowess
and even the anomaly power itself
with up to 200 ascension points to
unlock continued ascension progress will
be a constant companion in outright as
well slayer
even over hundreds of hours of play
sound good
of course it does but we're not done yet
outrider's wall slayer introduces
apocalypse tears
which will be replacing challenge tiers
even when playing expeditions
apocalypse tiers will be active across
all worlds layer content and will go up
to level 40 that means a new higher
level cap of level 75 tier 2.
speaking of gear apocalypse tiers also
introduce apocalypse gear
a third mod slot will propel your gear
to its most destructive form yet and in
combination with the many new and brutal
mods coming with worldslayer well
let's just say you'll be able to bring
some unseen crazy firepower to the table
that's already a lot to take in
throughout the outriders worldslayer
campaign you'll already have your hands
full of dealing with a rashkikal and her
minions
however
if you do manage to get past her well
the true end game still awaits
the trial of tarya kratar
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
that my friends is the tale for another
spotlight
now you've seen just some of what world
slayer has in store for you and we are
really excited for you to finally
experience the next step in the
outriders universe
it brings a brand new campaign where you
go toe-to-toe with a powerful altered
oreshka girl
we're extending the world tier system
and these are now called apocalypse
tears and go all the way up to level 40.
here you'll find two weapons and gear
with a third mod slots and we call this
apocalypse gear
and there will be new mods for you to
find and equip such as omen and noxious
spawns happy hunting
you'll also be able to develop your
power through the patch trees which
allow you to boost and further diversify
all four of your classes
and if all that wasn't enough the trial
of tarja gratar our new end game
combined with the new ascension system
will push even the most experienced
outriders to their limits and beyond
to close out today's show we're gonna
bring on our community maestro robbie to
preemptively answer any of the burning
questions we expect you to have about
world slayer
is he a cartoon or is he a real human
who knows but here he is
thanks lucy and hello everyone in this
community section we're going to go over
some of the final points in wild slayer
so without further delay let's just jump
right in
we've built worldslayer for both
existing players and new players alike
the original game with all of our
updates improvements and new horizon
content is also included with
worldslayer
[Music]
the new worldsair campaign picks up
right after the end of the original and
if you want to you'll be able to start
worldsair with a completely fresh
character that has been boosted to level
30
so you won't be lagging behind your
friends if you are a newbie and they're
hard on veterans
and don't forget about skipping your
head towards there you'll be able to
still progress through worldslayer first
and then jump back into the original
game's content
so if you're a complete newbie and you
pick up worlds there you'll have
everything included
but
what about existing players
well if you're returning outright's
player then firstly welcome back
secondly we've got you covered too with
the world's air upgrade option
if you buy the upgrade option on the
same platform you purchased at raiders
on all world slayer content will be
seamlessly integrated into your base
game
your characters and all your progress
armor weaponry will be waiting right
there for you when you face the new
trials ahead
of course there will always be questions
about the length of content and whilst
there was developed with having a
long-term progression system in mind
the main campaign awards there will get
you back into the swing of things but
every true lucy shooter fan knows it's
the end game and the loot hunt where
you'll be investing the lion's share of
your hours of course throughout all of
this you'll be pushing your apocalypse
tears as well as your ascension tears
ever higher
keeping the game challenging whilst also
min maxing your characters to the end
degree
to that end we expect the search for new
legendary gear and sets and especially
the hunt for apocalypse variants of said
gear to keep you very engaged for a very
long time
oh and one last thing before you go we
know the weight for the game is never
fun so if you pre-order either
worldslayer or the worldslayer upgrade
digitally you will get 48 hours early
access to the new mysteries that await
we hope that answers a lot of your
burning questions or words there that
you may have
be sure to send your follow-up questions
to the official outrightness social
channels and give us a follow for the
latest news on outriders
we are so excited for you to all jump
into worldslayer on june 30th back to
you lucy
thank you robbie now with the release of
outriders worldslayer coming at the end
of june pre-orders are live now
and for you newcomers if you pre-order
outriders worldslayer digitally you will
of course get access to outright as the
base game straight away so you can start
now and get ready for worldslayer
don't worry june will be here quicker
than you think time is flying
and that about summarizes it for today's
broadcast thank you so much for watching
everyone it has been a pleasure as
always and do join us for the next
broadcast where we deep dive into the
brand new world slayer end game the
trial of tire gritter
bye bye for now
[Music]
[Music]
foreign